bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors le directeur de
l'hôpital ne peut donc pas appliquer la
loi selon lui et en prend les
responsabilités c'est ce qu'il a dit ça
veut dire quoi est ce que vous savez
s'il peut être sanctionné pour ce qu'il
a dit est ce qu'il concert
bonjour en fait c'est pas tout à fait ça
ce qui se passait quand
le ministre de la santé à phil
déclarations médiatiques il y apprécie
pas moi ou il a bien constaté la
situation parce que j étais très loin et
qu'il fallait tenir compte de cette
situation
dames de la mesure on serait devant un
problème le problème c'est d'avoir du
personnel
fort que ça nous attendions un décret
notre ministériel pour pouvoir modifier
le décret du 7 août
malheureusement ça n'est jamais venu
sauf que la pression est arrivé au
moment même le 15 on m'a même chalet
interactivement
où les autorités avoir tous les éléments
en termes de vaccination ils se sont
retrouvés devant cette réalité c'est
qu'il y a pas seulement au chu il y a
quasiment dans tous les hôpitaux il ya
effectivement un fort taux de personnel
qui
rechignent à accepter non pas la
vaccination encore une fois mais
le vaccin
je suis j'aime à souligner ça c'est
qu'en fait je crois que si les autorités
font le choix de vaccins conventionnel
je ne pense pas que ce pays je crois
même je suis persuadé que ce personnel
va se ranger dans les rangs
concrètement est ce que les territoires
d'outre-mer l'on va pas mais de la
guadeloupe à ce que vous avez une date
en pour vous conformer à cette
obligation vaccinale des soignants c'est
qu'en métropole c'est le 15 septembre au
mois d'août est-ce que vous avez une
date précise
pas de date précise il ya simplement un
report en fonction de l'évolution de la
situation
certains parlent jusqu'au 15 novembre en
fonction aussi de comment le préfet va
va petit à petit des cv des joints en
termes de confinement de déconfinement
du moins mais il n'y a pas de date
précise ce qui est sûr c'est que il ya
une forte réticence il ya une forte
résistance même sur le terrain en dépit
du fait qu'il y a vous n'êtes pas sans
le savoir qu'il ya eu beaucoup de dégâts
en terme de mortalité
mais il faut aussi souligner qu'on ne
met pas seulement de covin mais ya eu
effectivement une faute
mentalités mais ça pour nous puisque les
autorités esprits ont leurs explications
nous nous avons la nôtre nous c'est
l'impréparation des autorités en terme
médical pour nous ce n'est pas du tout
la non vaccination c'est c'est le manque
de matériel le manque profite pour les
professionnels le manque l'impréparation
et bien entendu on sait que si nous
sommes sur un territoire où il ya
quasiment 100 mille personnes qui qui on
découvre obésité ac goven alors que nous
avons les autres tours
peter en piteux état
nous battons depuis des années la
situation je crois que la crise a dit et
contrairement à ce que les autorités
essaient de faire au travers de leur
propagande des voiles et met à nu
ce que nous dénonçons depuis des années
vous parlez d'impréparation et de manque
de matériel pour expliquer ce faible
taux de vaccination aux antilles là on
parle précisément de la guadeloupe ça
veut dire quoi que concrètement vous
n'avez pas les moyens dans les hôpitaux
de vacciner en masse non je
n'en ce n'est pas mon explication à ce
que je dis c'est que il ya une photo
montage mortalité et pour nous ce n'est
pas la question de la non vaccination
qui en est l'origine c'est ça que je dis
il y a au contraire au contraire pour la
vaccination il y a
pléthore d'organisations pour
celles à ras la religion
vous allez trouver
vaccinodromes
à tire larigot seulement la population
malgré la souffrance m'avait la
mentalité la population qu'une fois à
l'écran de 10 ans je vous rappelle que
nous sommes passés par un certain nombre
de situations de crise sanitaire déjà
est de même de 2 le scandale sanitaire
et nous n'avons pas la mémoire courte on
présente la vaccination aériennes comme
la seule porte de sortie alors qu'il y à
d'autres pays où
la démonstration est faite que cette
vaccination n'est pas si efficiente si
efficace que cela pour nous si on était
resté à des les
comment dirais-je être des traitements
précoces qui existe contrairement à ce
qu'on dit et est aussi à la recherche
fondamentale sur une vaccination
conventionnel à mon sens les choses nous
est pas arrivé à ce point là
merci en tout cas à vous d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de la cgtg santé quoi
donc merci free